first
big league start 10 and 10 in his minor
league career with the 346
era game two is the cubs able to take
game one at wrigley
7-1 that's craig's line drive base hit
down the line to left
jack peterson lumbers over there to get
it bets heads into second with a lead
off double
two men on chris taylor the number three
hitter ready to step
in and taylor hits a bouncing ball at
third boat he's got it steps on the back
throws to first double play beautiful
play david bodie
and then never set the feet ron and made
the sidearm throw across the diamond low
dug out beautifully by rizzo what a play
pitch to will smith here it is
big chop to bodhi one hop he's got it
throws to rizzo
in time keegan thompson puts a zero on
the board in the first inning of his
first
major league start dodgers don't score
after a half
trevor bauer on the mound has continued
on from his cy young season
making his seventh start in era of about
two and a half
and well better than a strikeout an
inning jack peterson out there at second
bryant the runner at first as the cubs
look to strike first
strikes him out with a high fast fall
for the first out
that is the pitch he's been trying to
find the range with
huge that he chased slightly above the
strike zone to get this strikeout
he stuck him out with the fastball
and bauer wriggles off the hook in the
bottom of the first inning two
strikeouts for trevor
let's see hitting 207 left-handed batter
strike three called kind of a delayed
call by stu
shorewater and muncie had a word or two
with shorewater
strikeout for keegan thompson another
3-2
and a bouncing ball through the left
side base hit
on the ten pits is still gonna left for
pollock second hit of the game for the
dodgers it's a one out single for
pollock
the 2-2 to rios bouncing ball right side
it's gloved by sogar go to second
one over to first that's gonna be a
double play it was actually vargas who
gloved it and
fed sogard 4-6-3 on the inning ending
twin killing
one away the batter is tony walters
sticks with it and strikes him out yeah
went upstairs the fastball that's
that's a big pitch for trevor bauer here
it comes
and he got into swinging miss he strikes
him out four strikeouts for bauer so far
and the vargas left at second base no
runs no hits
one left gavin lux will lead things off
for the dodgers then trevor bauer and
then mookie betts
smash on the ground one hop to sogar
gloves it
the cubs have the picket fence set up
over on the right side
sogard loving that one hopper makes the
play
one down no score third inning for
trevor bauer
he swings and misses strike three and
that's out number two
strikeout number two for keegan thompson
as betts hits a sky-high pop fly on the
infield
vargas and sogard are there it's gonna
be vargas
to make the call and the catch take a
look at all the guys coming up hugging
him
and you know he didn't get a lot of hits
as a dodgers but he had a lot of big
moments with that team and he had 382
last year in the postseason that they
went on to be crowned world series
champions
power gets him strikeout number five for
trevor bauer one away in the third
that one lying to the left field that's
a base hit
pollock will pick it up bryant to second
hit
and chris is in with a double another
extra base hit for chris brown who
hooked it down the line
he's got 12 doubles now the 1-1
a ground ball to first base muncie grabs
it he'll step on the bag and keep going
in the direction of the dugout
that'll be it for the cubs in the third
inning trevor bauer able to work around
the one out double by chris bryant
and after three full at wrigley field
it's the dodgers nothing cubs nothing
game two of a double header corey seeger
at the plate here comes the pitch
ground ball up the first baseline
fairball scooped up by rizzo the toss
to keegan thompson covering first in
time
and seeger is retired taylor with a
one-out walk and it'll bring up will
smith
in the air right field towards the
corner
hayward and jason able to make the catch
taylor will tag the throw is too late
i really wish this ballpark was packed
right now because
i know the type of ovation that these
cub fans would be giving this young man
[Music]
[Applause]
heck of a job by keegan thompson
and you can see the way the infielders
respond to david ross as well
and he'll feel the love in the dugout
team strikeouts against five walks
10 in the third innings of work for rex
brothers delivers three
side retired the dodgers leave a man
on second and brothers gets the cubs
out of the gym cubs and dodgers are
scoreless jason hayward leading things
off here in the fourth against trevor
bauer he swings and hits one in the air
to deep right field going back his bets
looking up
gone a solo home run for
jason hayward cubs take the lead one to
nothing over the dodgers here in the
fourth
it's so important to get the lead in
these seven inning ball games
and now bryant's gonna get a chance with
the bases loaded
this is why you buy a ticket here you
turn your tv on
so here we go all loaded up the payoff
pitch for
bauer to chris bryant strike three right
down the middle he took it
and bauer pounding his chest with his
right fist
as he walks off to the first base dugout
cubs leave him loaded but they get a run
four walks a hit
batter in the air out towards left
center pretty well struck
taylor out there taylor jumps and he
can't get it rizzo
racing for second anthony's headed for
third
and he's got a triple second of the year
[Music]
and right that settles under it makes
the catch roseau bluffs and draws the
throw but that's all
big first out for trevor bauer so that's
it for trevor bauer runnerman third one
gone
one-nothing game at the bottom of the
fifth
victor gonzalez into the game
[Music]
ground by the first muncie comes home
rizzo tries to dance his way away from
the tag but
smith applies it two gone here in the
fifth
here's 02. did he go he did
strike three and victor gonzalez is able
to get out of it
enchanted mvp for chris pride kb
base is loaded he struck him out
fastball at 98 two gone in the six
two two to rizzo swung on and missed
strike three got him to chase a slider
in the dirt
a houdini as trynan works himself out of
a basis loaded no out jam
in this second game only a home run by
jason hayward is the difference in the
game
max muncie at the plate muncie has
struck out twice
[Music]
[Applause]
now justin turner will be the pinch
hitter
justin has been among the league leaders
early in the year
naples fires that is to the backstop
and the ricochet allows the go-ahead run
to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
second run in extra innings and it's 3-1
la and the cubs now down to their final
out
baez waits from mitch white the pitch
[Applause]
a rocket to left field as if on qjd
he gets on that one in field in man at
third bryant the winning rug
2-2 swinging a ball ripped right field
that's going back gets over his head
david body walks it off here comes kb
and the cubs sweep the double header
cubs win